how do you guys make decisions when you
purchase things I think it's very
similar to that I mean it you don't have
a thousand watches right you've got some
watches that you really appreciate the
craftsmanship of its art right in a way
and it's art that you really really
appreciate I mean when it comes to those
hobbies that's how that's how I look at
it or some hobbies I have that that
serve the things that I have actually
serve a purpose like I snowboard so you
know all the stuff I have that goes
along with that i am i absolutely have
one pair of you know snow pants and a
pair of gloves and i don't have multiple
pairs of pants and multiple pairs of
eyes I have exactly what I need
yeah but I'll tell you what man I wish I
could sit here and say that you know if
all your listeners they wouldn't watch
their documentary they bought all our
books they will never want to buy
anything again I mean that's just that's
just not the case that's not what we're
that's not what we're offering I still
as one of the minimalists I still enjoy
buying stuff I mean it's still an
impulse that I have been able to rein in
but I still have yeah but man I'll tell
you like when I hope there's a TMZ
somewhere of you with like a Prada bag
or something yeah well you know it's
funny man is as the minimalist
everything we do is steeped in irony I
mean it is yeah irony is not lost with
us like you know when 2,000 people will
show up at one of our events or you know
people who download our podcasts or
whatever like there's so many things
deep in irony with us but but what I was
gonna say though about me still wanting
to buy stuff is I remember I have this
these pair of overalls that's like a
snow they're for snowboarding and like
going on the hunt for those like I
really really it's not it's not that I
was getting some kind of like fix off of
it but I really enjoyed the experience
of like comparing different overalls and
and reading the reviews and like really
making this deliberate decision but
buying a pair of these overall is that I
know are gonna last me you know five to
ten years yeah and and finally getting
it and I remember like being on the
mountain and wearing those for the first
time and it's crazy like I just
even realize until having this pair of
overalls like I'm standing up on the
mountain I'm like wow like having
comfortable equipment for going down a
mountain on a snowboard
it is a game-changer in a lot of ways so
we certainly do appreciate stuff
especially you know art and there are
many different crafts that that I can
definitely appreciate but what what it
comes down to is what actually does add
value to my life like Kevin you're an
awesome dude and there are many like I
love your house man there's a lot of
things I'm like man Kevin's I would love
to you know have a really simple house
like this I mean I know it's it's a big
house but it's a very simple home and I
can tell that things are done very
deliberately but I could very easily be
like man Kevin's a cool guy I want to be
like Kevin I want to start collecting
watches and like those are the things
that I think we have to look out for
that's what I have to look out for is
really asking why why do I have this
impulse if I act on this impulse what is
that going to do for me what's it gonna
do for my household the people around me
I think minimalism helps us to ask those
may be extra quiet maybe not deeper
questions but extra questions prompts
you like when do you find that those
come up there are certain times where
you guys feel like oh I'm catching
myself like this is something that like
how do you teach people I guess like
obviously your books probably explain
this but how do you teach people what's
the first steps to get started well I
think the very first step is asking a
question and that question for me was
how might your life be better with less
and because it reframed it if reframes
in the way that you identify what the
benefits are because getting rid of the
stuff like we talked about a moment ago
that's not the happiness how might your
life be better with less like you'll
answer that question differently from
Jordan over there or different from Ryan
different from me and that highlights
what the benefits of simplifying might
be for you for me it was getting out of
debt yeah but then I uncovered all these
other additional benefits like improved
relationships because I started getting
rid of toxic people in my life or people
who just didn't share the same values
maybe they weren't toxic interesting you
can apply this to people - absolutely I
mean I think I think it's it's equally
important right but when it comes to -
why what are the first steps that that's
an important one when it comes to
bringing new things into my
life though I have some sort of stopgaps
there we have something called the 3030
rule and so if something costs more than
$30 I wait at least 30 hours to buy it
that's especially helpful with Amazon
yeah so easy it's not that I don't have
the money I can blow thirty dollars on
something but it makes me at least stop
and say okay does this thing or it will
this thing add value to my life well a
serve a purpose or bring me joy and then
also I'm asking myself is this the best
use of that $30 great maybe I can
justify yeah it's gonna add value to my
life but maybe there's a better use of
this $30 or hundred dollars or two
thousand dollars or whatever it may be
is this the best use of that money and
quite often the answer is no like this
is a good use of the money but I'd
rather do something else with it and and
just that pause allows me to ruminate in
what I'm about to do and I'm on the
precipice of my next bad decision here
let me let me stop and pause before I
leap off of this cliff or after those 30
hours of him like yeah definitely have
decided this is the right thing to bring
into my life great and the same thing is
true when I'm letting when I'm letting
go because even now at age 37 I've been
a minimalist for about almost 10 years
now and the things that added value to
my life when I first embrace this
lifestyle 28 radically different now you
know I've got a 5 year old I have a
partner we live together we're in a
different City and so I realized like oh
the things that add value today may not
add value tomorrow so I also have to be
willing to let go of the new things I
bring into my life so I can make room
for whatever the future might hold yeah
you